is queer a bad word the mainstream media
and big tech are now ik waiting the word
queer with the n-word we will explain
why there is no comparison between the
two terms then the New York Times
publishes the most defamatory fact free
piece in the gray lady's long and sordid
history we will pick it apart point by
point a radical feminist omits abortion
is murder a thirteen-year-old pro-life
activist gets booed for saying abortion
is murder and President Trump wins big
with Mexico I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
so much to get to today we've got to
talk about all those awful terrible
bigots that the New York Times wrote
about there's awful bigots like Dave
Rubin or Phil DeFranco or Milton
Friedman we will also analyze the left's
new campaign to censor conservatives but
first if you are carrying around
revolving debt that means that you are
not paying off your credit card every
month and you could be paying thousands
an interest every year that you don't
have - some of my friends have done this
it's very stupid don't do it don't carry
around these high interest credit card
rates when you could go to Lending Club
and consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment it's just smart it's just not
being a total dummy with your money
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards I
know I used to have credit card debt now
I don't do I I'm perfectly fine having
other sorts of debt but I will not carry
around this high interest credit card
debt and you shouldn't either go to
Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days this
is like millennial proof it's so you
don't even have to move it just gets too
positive that's why it's the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Knowles Canada
wles check your rate in minutes borrow
up to 40 grand Lending Club com /
Knowles kano wles
Lending Club com / anoles all loans made
by Webb bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender I have got to start off the show
today with a quick point that is
probably going to get this episode
kicked off of YouTube and maybe get me
arrested and thrown in jail by the
left-wing speech police but that is the
problem itself so I will just say it
queer is not a bad word it's not it's a
perfectly fine word so it's a word
that's been around for a very long time
and it's perfectly fine the left right
now is trying to equate the word queer
with the N word and this is absolutely
absurd
so it's absurd
for a few reasons the first and most
obvious is that I can say the word queer
I can't say the n-word when I'm
referring to the n-word I have to say
the n-word so right off the bat we see
these are not exactly similar or
circumstances now the mainstream media
are trying to change that right now I've
noticed in the last few days news
networks are bleeping the word queer
because the left's campaign to get this
word banned is working but they are not
similar at all another reason that the
word queer is not like the n-word is
that the word queer is a very old word
it has very broad meaning far beyond the
narrow application to gay people the
word queer is 500 years old it means
strange or odd the reason that it is
used to describe gay people is because
gay people have sexual practices that
are strange or odd just by definition
they are not like most people's sexual
practices like 97 or 98 percent of the
population if if people are doing
something that only 2 or 3 percent of
the population are doing by definition
that's a little unusual
at least that's where the word queer
comes from now in recent years the word
queer has been used to refer to gay
people with both a positive connotation
and a negative connotation this is also
like the word gay by the way when even
when we say gay people the word gay has
only been used to refer to gay people
for the last 50 years and what does gay
mean gay means happy that's what it
meant now the word almost exclusively is
referred referring to people who are
homosexual queer has a lot of usages for
a very long time the n-word does not the
n-word is only a slur for black people
we don't even really know the history of
the n-word or the etymology of it some
people erroneously think that it derives
from the word Negro it doesn't there's
no evidence of that or they think it
derives from the word niggardly it does
not they're also not related and now
presumably it does derive from words
that or it is at least related to words
that are associated with blackness
Sonique renoir niger nigeria this
country nigeria
it at least probably has some relation
to those words but we don't really know
where it derives from we
do know that the n-word hard are itself
is only used for centuries as a negative
slur for black people the word queer has
a zillion applications it's a generic
word another reason why the why queer is
not like the n-word is that queer is
used by gay people themselves to refer
to themselves if the word queer is a
hateful slur then the acronym LGBTQ is
also a hateful slur the Q stands for
queer but also now in later years it's
also been used to refer to questioning
like you don't know if you're gay or
straight or whatever but the Q still
stands for queer now one argument
against this is they'll say well the
left will observe black people have
taken the n-word and re-appropriated it
for themselves so in the same way gay
people are reappropriation the word
queer again this argument totally breaks
down because it's not just gay people
who are using the word queer for
themselves or some derivation like you
don't have the hard are they'll just say
quia or something in rap songs no that's
not how it works everybody refers to gay
people as queer politicians who are gay
or straight or whatever all refer to the
LGBTQ community corporations refer to
the LGBTQ community the government
refers to the LGBTQ community so it's
not just that it's a term that only I
can use but you can't use it and that's
our word no it's used by everybody now
could you imagine a politician referring
to the N word community could you
imagine a government office saying
listen we just want to welcome all of
the in word community here you'd have a
riot you'd have riots in the streets how
about in academia the word queer is used
regularly in scholarship there's a
famous book called queering elementary
education
could you imagine a book called n
wording elementary education probably
would not be allowed on Amazon for very
long but you can get queering elementary
education on Amazon academic journals
regularly refer to queer times or
queering could you imagine n-word times
or in wording there are whole academic
departments at universities around this
kind
called queer studies now it's true there
are there are similarly disciplines
called african-american studies or
africana studies or black studies there
are no departments called
inward studies something tells me there
would be some lawsuits against that
university if they had those departments
there's no comparison whatsoever the
left however is insisting that there is
one they're trying to get this word
banned they're trying to not get it
banned from the left using it the left
is still allowed to use it on television
or on YouTube we're in the popular
culture
it's just conservatives who are no
longer allowed to use it which is
obviously absurd now we're saying that
the only way that you can ascertain if
someone is publicly allowed to use a
word is if you can predict and read
their minds and and understand the
motivations that they have and there are
thoughts about all of these various
sexual questions then we can determine
who's allowed to use the word queer and
who's not that's crazy
but let's just say I'll take it even
further let's say for a second that the
word queer did primarily have a negative
connotation it doesn't we just had Pride
Parade yesterday queer word everywhere
LGBTQ it's on every building it's on
every business so it does not primarily
have a negative connotation but let's
say that it did what that means then is
that what the leftist censors want is
for us as a society to no longer be able
to come to our own moral conclusions
about certain sexual acts what that
means is that now you can't go on
YouTube and say I approve of certain
sexual acts but I disapprove of other
sexual acts I have a view of sexual
morality that says you can do this and
that but you can't do this in that what
this means is that now on YouTube if a
priest or a rabbi or an imam went on and
made a youtube video in which they
expressed their orthodox views about
sexual morality their views that have
been held for at least 1400 if not 2,000
or more years that would be hate speech
that would be banned they would be de
platform they would be kicked off of
YouTube and if the left gets their way
they would
be banned from polite society for
expressing the Orthodox and traditional
views of every major world religion
anybody who holds Orthodox views in
Christianity Judaism Islam any of these
things what the left wants to censor you
from polite society you can't say that
well some people say okay what if the
the priest and the rabbi and the Imam
they can go on YouTube they can discuss
they're certainly terrible views of
sexual morality but they have to do it
in a respectful way how can they do that
if someone's going to go on YouTube and
say I think you're going to go to hell
if you keep doing this thing is that
respect that's not respectful what if a
rabbi goes on YouTube and he quotes
Leviticus major book of the Bible which
refers to homosexual acts as an
abomination regardless of your views of
sex or day sex or whatever do you think
that a rabbi should be banned from
youtube for reading the Bible that is
the conclusion of what they are trying
to do this is radical what they're
trying what they're trying to do it's
this is what they always do they have
this radical idea that now if you quote
a book from the Bible or if you disagree
with the very very recent modern leftist
orthodoxy about sexual morality if you
disagree with it with what has only
become a mainstream view in the last 10
years or so that you are radical you're
crazy you're radicalized that's what the
left is saying but that idea that that
they're saying is itself a totally
radical idea
you're saying that even Barack Obama's
view of sexuality while he was president
which said that marriage is between a
man and a woman even that view is
radical bigoted hateful should be D
platform shouldn't be allowed in polite
society that is the true radicalism and
what the left always does because they
project and they invert reality is the
left is saying no no you who hold the
views that everyone has held for the
entire history of civilization you are
really the radical one it's a complete
lie
the New York Times shows this explicitly
in the most dishonest ridiculous I mean
actually funny
article that they have published in my
lifetime they published it over the
weekend it was the main story in The New
York Times home page this obviously took
a long time to put together it's called
the making of a YouTube radical and
they're using it in conjunction with
voxcom and in conjunction with YouTube
and Google themselves to censor
conservatives on the Internet we'll get
to that in a second but first let me
tell you why I look so good I'm feeling
a little proud of my nice baby smooth
face today because of Dollar Shave Club
use Dollar Shave Club has everything
that I need to look feel and smell my
best you might have seen I put out a
video or a picture rather on Friday of
me licking a cake that says taxation is
theft and I was shirtless and I was just
you might think Michael how does your
skin get so smooth how do you look so
mmm like a little snack well the answer
is Dollar Shave Club I never have to go
to the store because Dollar Shave Club
it sends me everything I need right to
my door also they keep me fully stocked
on what I use so that I don't run out I
don't even need to think about it which
is the key because I don't think about
these things so before Dollar Shave I
would be using whatever razor I had
reusable or something and I would shave
with it until it was just a perfectly
rusted piece of metal and I don't know
I'd be like ducking tetanus every time I
shaved
now Dollar Shave I don't need to think
about that they have everything you need
to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe from your hair your skin to
your face and it whatever product you
want I mean they have got it and they
automatically keep you stocked up you
determine what you want when you want it
so you're not gonna get overloaded with
stuff you don't need it shows up right
at your door from once a month to once
every six weeks plus there they have
their handsome discount which means the
more you buy the more you save right now
they've got a bunch of starter sets you
can try for just five bucks like the
oral care kit you can get the starter
set for five dollars right now go to
Dollar Shave calm slash cough fa co v fe
fe that is Dollar Shave com
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough FAC a VF
e fe it is fabulous and you're gonna
love it this New York Times article the
most dishonest tripe I don't know that
there was an honest word in the article
it's called the Mae
king of a YouTube radical by kevin ruse
a fake journalist I'm just gonna pick it
apart point by point I can't even give
you just the broad overview every
paragraph is a lie so it starts out on
the it was on mobile it was on the
website lots of photos and it was all of
these awful PB s-- radicals do you know
who the radicals were ben shapiro
probably the most mainstream
conservative voice in the country ben
shapiro
dave rubin dave rubin who is amiable to
a fault Dave Reubens whole show as he
has people who have different points of
view on and then they disgust them dave
rubin radically presenting both sides
and taking the center of an argument do
girls Phil DeFranco I don't even think
that guy's conservative and then do you
this is my favorite one of all these
pictures because they mix them in with
people who are maybe a little racist
maybe a little bigoted maybe you've
never heard of a really extreme and then
in the middle of it is Milton Friedman
Milton Friedman probably the most famous
economist of the 20th century he's just
a guy who supports free markets and free
economics and he's like a grandfatherly
figure who won a Nobel Prize in Economic
Allah cording to the New York Times
there's not a single person in the world
who could make this pencil remarkable
statement not at all the wood from which
it's made for all I know comes from a
tree that was cut down in the state of
Washington to cut down that tree it took
a song to make the saw it took steel to
make the steel it took iron ore this
black Center we call it lead but it's
really graphite compressed graphite I'm
not sure where it comes from but I think
it comes from some mines in South
America this red top up here the eraser
bit a rubber probably comes from Malaya
where the rubber tree isn't even native
it was imported from South America by
some businessmen with the help of the
British government this brass ferrule
I haven't the slightest idea where it
came from
or the yellow paint where the paintin
made the black lines or the glue that
holds it together literally thousands of
people cooperated to make this pencil
okay David Duke right Richard Spencer
calm down with your description of how
different people's around the world can
cooperate in free markets to produce
goods at a relatively low price for
consumers around the world are I calm
down there mister Adolph gosh that's a
radical according to the New York Times
that was my favorite one all of them
were ridiculous but that was my favorite
one how does it begin you see the
makings of a YouTube radical story
begins with all these pictures you
scroll through and it says caleb kane
was a college dropout looking for
direction he turned to youtube you
scroll up soon he was pulled into a
far-right universe watching thousands of
videos filled with conspiracy theories
misogyny and racism yeah that's how I
would describe Milton Friedman
conspiracy theories misogyny and racism
because he talked about the color of the
pencil I guess that's racist then the
final the final line I was brainwashed
and here you see the point of the
article from the very beginning what the
what the New York Times is trying to
tell you but the whole left is trying to
tell you is that we don't really have
any choice we don't really have free
will we don't really have the ability to
watch whatever we want on the Internet
see that's what the internet does it
lets you watch whatever you want it's
not like the old mainstream media that
keeps people out there gatekeepers know
on the Internet you can see whatever you
want their thesis is no you can't you
really have no choice you're just
brainwashed you're brainwashed by
yourself you have brainwashed yourself
with YouTube helping you along it's not
about free will it's all about the
all-powerful algorithm capital a this is
essential to the leftist argument that
YouTube has to censor conservatives they
say it's not about the viewers it's not
even about the content creators on
YouTube
Carlos maza from Viacom was saying that
he said look of course I want steven
crowder censored but it's not really
about steven crowder
it's about the algorithm it's all of so
they're trying to get YouTube to
this the work of leftists to censor
their opponents so the author of this
this guy Kevin ruse what do we know
about him well we found out through a
simple Twitter search he's friends with
Carlos masa at least he knows him
they've interacted before months and
months ago he had tweeted out something
about how he'd been working for a long
time for months on an article carlos
masa thanked him in february for all the
work that he's done and then Kevin Russa
liked the Carlos maza tweet these guys
know each other they're interacting with
one another online then they open up
this story I mean the timing is a little
suspect - Carlos masa from voxcom
launches his crusade on conservatives to
get them kicked off of YouTube on May
30th two days before Pride Month then
not three four days later a little a
little longer I guess a week later the
New York Times publishes this major
piece this piece took a lot longer than
a week
to produce obviously there was some
communication going on here as YouTube
is ramping it up this is an all on
assault not just a beginning of Pride
Month that more importantly at the
beginning of the 2012 20 election cycle
so the New York Times piece begins the
common thread found in many of these
stories of radicalization on YouTube and
it's cotton its recommendation algorithm
the software that determines which
videos appear on users home pages and
inside the up next sidebar next to a
video that is playing the algorithm is
responsible for more than 70% of all
time spent on the site because what does
the algorithm do it recommends similar
videos this makes perfect sense if
you're watching a video of Milton
Friedman maybe you want to watch another
video of Milton Friedman
I'm sure well now they've probably
changed it but I'm sure if you're
watching a video of this show
it'll probably recommend some other
stuff that I've done why cuz you're
obviously interested in what I'm doing
and so you want to see more of it or
maybe similar things I mean that's just
natural and they're saying this is
terrible
so this is the set up what YouTube is
doing is they need to change the
algorithm to suppress the right-wing
material before 2020 before we get
another Republican election I mean
that's that's I think the long game of
all of this the piece goes on they're
talking about
this kid this kid Caleb Akane who says
he was a that he was radicalized
right-wing radical because of YouTube
and this took place over the series of
three years 2016-2017 into 2018 and he
just became more and more right-wing and
and he became a total radical so what
did he do well this is what the New York
Times says if alienation was one
ingredient in mr. Cain's radicalization
and persuasive partisans like stefan
molyneux a youtube creator or another
the third was a series of product
decisions a YouTube made starting back
in 2012 in March of that year
YouTube's engineers made an update to
the site's recommendations algorithm for
years the algorithm had been programmed
to maximize views by showing users
videos they were likely to click on so
they're saying this is some nefarious
thing what no what is really happening
is YouTube is giving people more of what
they want to see should YouTube be
giving people stuff that they don't want
to see it should it be like you go to a
restaurant and you say I really like
clam chowder and they say oh perfect
here's a taco bowl I'm sure you say no
but I really like this clam chowder say
yeah but you can't you can't have any
more of that you have to have it - no of
course businesses want to cater to what
you want I mean they want the customer
to be happy the customer's always right
New York Times goes on by the night of
November 8th 2016 this is my favorite
paragraph in the whole thing mr. Kane's
transformation was complete he spent
much of the night watching clips of MS
Clinton's supporters crying after the
election was called in mr. Trump's favor
his YouTube viewing history shows that
at 1:41 a.m. just before bed he turned
on a live stream hosted by steven
crowder with the title Trump wins so on
election night this kid this radically
started out he was kind of a moderate
liberal guy on election night he was
watching videos titled Trump wins on the
night that Trump won that's the that's
the big that's the radicalization is
that on a night when most of America
voted in Donald Trump he was celebrating
that the guy who won the presidency won
the presidency the
cuz he was watching videos about he
might not have even been celebrating it
he was just watching videos about it
still doesn't seem very radical does it
no of course not
it's all just this this ambiance it's
all the pictures the graphics so the
word is radical in the title so what
actually happened to this guy what the
New York Times as always like 20
paragraphs in they give away the whole
story and they show that actually what
they're saying happened is the opposite
of what actually happened we'll get to
that in a second but first speaking of
great stories code names deception
gadgets this might seem like something
out of the movies but these are just
some of the essential components of
being a spy we got a lot of spies around
in the world
terney general bar was talking about
this the other day every country has
spies and most spies are ordinary
forgettable people which makes them old
more dangerous what does it really take
to be a spy every week the PAR cast
original espionage tells the stories of
the world's most incredible undercover
missions and how these covert operations
succeeded or sometimes failed find out
the real world spy tactics required to
impersonate exploit and infiltrate the
most confidential places in the world
you are going to be fascinated by the
story of FBI official mark felt does
that name ring a bell maybe not mark
felt was the anonymous FBI informant who
went by the name deep throat he gave the
crucial information to the Washington
Post that led to President Nixon's
resignation overwatered it there are
episodes on British codebreaker Alan
Turing as well as triple agent Henry
Derek or am i pronouncing there
correctly they're out right now it's
really really cool because we all have
the idea of spying movies and what it's
like the real-life stories are more
interesting than the movies search for
and subscribe to espionage wherever you
listen to podcasts search espionage or
visit Park ascom slash espionage to
listen now so you're reading this New
York Times story and you think this the
guy doesn't sound very radical at all so
far the story is just about a guy who
finds some right-wing videos on YouTube
and he watches them right so does it get
any more radical than that are we gonna
actually get with the New York Times is
promising well listen to what they write
one channel run by Jared Taylor the
editor of the white man
journalist magazine American Renaissance
posted videos with titles like refugee
invasion is European suicide others
posted clips of interviews with white
supremacists like Richard Spencer and
David Duke mr. Cain never never bought
into the far rights most extreme views
like Holocaust denial or the need for a
white ethno state he said still
far-right ideology bled into his daily
life
he began referring to himself as a trad
con a traditional conservative committed
to old-fashioned gender norms he dated
an evangelical Christian woman and he
fought with his liberal friends by the
way that last part isn't that isn't even
true he disagreed with his liberal
friends he didn't fight with them what
are they saying
actually happened they're saying on the
right wing YouTube there are people who
are vicious vile racist neo-nazis caleb
kane never listened to any of them or
really believed them at all but they
exist
well i thought the article was about the
making of a radical you said this was
about the making of a youtube radical
and then you explained so you described
some views that actually are radical
right before you say that the kid never
believed any of them the most radical
thing that this kid did according to the
new york times his own reporting is he
referred to himself as a traditional
conservative that's it guys that's it
when they taught when they use the term
the alt-right on the left when they use
that term they're just talking about you
and me they're just talking about
anybody who believes that the genders
are different so they said they said he
started to believe in gender norms oh he
believes that men and women are
different
okay and then he disagreed with his
liberal friends oh the guy who has
conservative viewpoints disagreed with
people who have different viewpoints
okay and this is the most shocking thing
of all he dated a Christian girl he
dated a Christian girl that's that's the
radicalization is that a guy in 2019 in
America dated a Christian girl and
called himself a conservative that's it
that's the most extreme thing in the
whole
article I don't know him this is a very
long article do you see what they do
they say look at all these awful people
David Duke Richard Spencer probably
Adolf Hitler himself yeah this guy never
listened to any of them but but they're
there and then he dated a Christian girl
now that's what makes him radical so it
goes on he says in 2018 nearly four
years after mr. Cain had begun watching
right-wing YouTube videos a new kind of
video began appearing in his
recommendations these videos were made
by left-wing creators okay so starts in
2016 he's watching right-wing videos and
then a couple years later he starts
watching left-wing videos now why did
the left-wing video pop up I guess maybe
they changed the algorithm or he was
just searching for titles that brought
up some left-wing videos and he started
watching them maybe the videos kind of
looked a little similar to the
right-wing videos and then he became a
left-winger notice how they take all the
human agency out of it it's not that in
2016 he started watching you right-wing
videos and he started to think of
himself as more conservative and then in
2018 he started to watch more left-wing
videos and then he started to think of
himself as more liberal that's not what
happened because he's not allowed to
have any thought people don't have any
agency or free will what really happened
is the algorithm the secret all-powerful
algorithm was controlling him in
brainwashing him and and moving his mind
that's obviously not how human beings
work that's not how knowledge works and
then then they say they said they're
quoting Caleb Cain now the kid I just
kept watching more and more of that
content sympathizing and empathizing
with the left-wing creator and also
seeing that wow she really knows what
she's talking about mr. Cain said there
is nothing newsworthy about this at all
what that guy just said is I took in
some information and thought about it
and it changed my mind and then I took
in other information and then I changed
my mind again there is nothing
newsworthy about changing your mind
people do that all the time and then
they talk about his new life so I guess
they say has been radicalized and I
guess he's come out of the
radicalization we've never seen any
radicalization in the whole
article but that's what they say then at
the end they say what is most surprising
about mr. Cain's new life is new
left-wing life on the surface is how
similar it feels to the old one he still
watches dozens of YouTube videos every
day and hangs on the words of his
favorite creators it is still difficult
at times to tell where the YouTube
algorithm stops and his personality
begins no it's not it's not difficult to
decide that you are you have no respect
for this guy obviously and you have no
respect for anyone else New York Times
so you think that they don't have any
brains in their head that they're just
robots zombies being controlled by
YouTube but it's not difficult to figure
out where someone's personality ends and
where YouTube begins what they think and
say and do is their personality and the
videos they watch or the videos they
watch or the books that they read we
it's we all learn from what we see and
what we hear and what we observe so this
they're saying YouTube is special and
different because there are videos and
you can learn things from videos oh okay
what if he read a book let's say he read
a book from Milton Friedman for instance
let's say you've read a book on
Friedman's economics and then he thought
I agree with this Milton Friedman guy I
think he's got good economic views would
you say that books are now the path to
radicalization the library the making of
a library radical no of course not we
learn that's what we do that New York
Times is pretending that the YouTube
algorithm is the first magical device
ever to influence how people think
everything influences how we think
conversations influence how we think
observations movies events critical
thinking it's it's not the algorithm
either it's not it's not the order of
the books on the bookshelf in the
library it's the content that's what
changes how we think content is
thought-provoking and this the last
paragraph of this stupid article gives
away the whole game they write they're
quoting Caleb Kane here YouTube is the
place to put out a message he said but
I've learned now that you can't go to
YouTube and think that you're getting
some kind of education because you're
not what what are you getting them
what if you watch a college lecture on
YouTube you're not getting an education
what if you learn something that you
didn't know before you're not getting an
education
what if sweet little ELISA does this all
the time you go on YouTube and you look
up a new recipe how to make some new
meal and then you learn how to make it
and then you cook it that's a that's an
education what if you look up some
academic question obviously you're
getting an education but this is what
the left has to do they're saying this
is not about education it's only about
entertainment see this is critical to
the argument that YouTube should censor
conservatives because even the left if
these guys were really being honest and
they said we want to censor ideas that
we disagree with because we can't refute
them with argument even the left
probably doesn't want to say that they
want to do that they at least pretend to
oppose academic censorship censorship in
the name of ideas so what the left has
to do is pretend that YouTube is just
sort of entertainment they have to
pretend that it's just sort of
right-wingers being provocateurs they
always use this term to refer to
right-wingers provocateurs or radicals
or fringe or whatever because what they
what they need to say is that right wing
commentators and speakers they're not
dealing in ideas they're not engaging in
arguments they are they're just
interested in shock value and there is
nothing new about this argument this
argument which the New York Times thinks
is brand new
Carlos Moss at YouTube they all think
it's brand new they've been making this
for 50 years we'll tell you what the
argument is in a second but first I have
got to go to daily wire.com get off of
youtube
we're probably already off of YouTube
because i use the word queer so we're
probably already off there anyway go to
daily wire ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the end of a Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get them
out wall show you have to ask questions
in the mailbag that's coming up on
Thursday you got to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom and
you get left us tears tumblr mmm that's
good
mmm oh that's radical that is that's
Totally Rad dude that's a totally
radical drink today out of the leftist
tears tumblr go get yours before you
drown we'll be right back
in 1969 a major leftist intellectual
Lionel trilling made the argument quote
liberalism is not only the dominant but
even the sole intellectual tradition in
the United States
as if to say there's no reason to engage
with these conservative ideas get get
them off of YouTube get them out get
them out of the public square he even
said it more directly he said that
conservatives don't express themselves
in ideas but in quote irritable mental
gestures which seek to resemble ideas
he said that in 1969 how many decades
later they say the same thing they say
all these people talking on on YouTube
these are not these people are not
dealing in ideas they're just the kind
of resemble ideas but they're not
they're wicked they're awful they're
dangerous we have to get rid of them
they've been using this argument for
half a century to silence conservatives
they're gonna use it for half century
more ironically this is the best part of
the New York Times article this stupid
article the arguments that they present
undercut the thesis of the article the
thesis of the article is that this guy
was radicalized to become a right-wing
radical he started out left-wing then he
became right-wing actually though this
guy's own YouTube searches which he gave
to the New York Times to write this
article show exactly the opposite
he started out watching far right-wing
videos and then he ended up watching
left-wing videos if he was radicalized
in any direction he was radicalized to
the left
this is the New York Times admits this
they say he started out watching
far-right videos by people like stefan
molyneux in 2016 who is stefan molyneux
he's a libertarian guy very is an
extreme libertarian he calls himself an
anarcho-capitalist so yeah he does have
extreme viewpoints started out in 2016
then he moved on to the intellect well
that first men he moved on to crowder
so crowder a more mainstream figure than
stefan molyneux then he moves on to the
intellectual dark web specifically
people like Dave Rubin and Joe Rogan so
he's moved
Reuben is a liberal I mean he's a
self-described liberal he's a centrist
guy Joe Rogan is sort of center-left guy
so he's moving to the left and then he
lands on left-wing videos by 2018 so I
mean we say this all the time with the
left the left gets everything exactly
backwards they're saying the guy was
radicalized to the right he actually was
radicalized to the left all of the
movement of his searches goes to the
left and of course there aren't really
any radicals in the whole bunch Ben
Shapiro Phil DeFranco Milton Friedman no
radicals at all also he was never
radicalized they say that he rejected
Nazism they admit that in the article he
didn't do anything he didn't believe
anything out of the ordinary the most
extreme thing he believed is that he was
a traditional conservative it is a not
only a worthless article because it
first of all it conveys nothing
newsworthy it lies about its thesis and
it defames virtually everybody that it
mentions it is it is wholly without
merit except that it will be used to
advance the left-wing agenda to censor
conservatives one of the great things
about YouTube that accidentally this
article sort of shows is that you can
see both sides of an argument for now I
mean they as we are speaking right now
that YouTube is getting rid of that they
are stopping you from seeing both sides
of the argument but this was one of the
advantages of YouTube as you could just
see kind of get all sorts of ideas and
then form your own conclusion and this
became pretty apparent over the weekend
there was a video of an abortion
supporter and she was this radical
feminist named Sophie Lewis and she put
out a video explaining theological
arguments the extreme arguments but the
logical arguments for abortion in the
past the strategies that our side has
tended to use have included a kind of
seeding of ground to our enemies we tend
to say that abortion is indeed very bad
but or we say luckily it's not killing
luckily it's just a health care right we
have very little to lose at the moment
when it comes to abortion
and I'm interested in winning radically
and I wonder if we could think about
defending abortion as a right to stop
doing gestational work abortion is in my
opinion and I recognize how
controversial this is a form of killing
it is a form of killing that we need to
be able to defend I am NOT interested in
where a human life starts to exist I got
to give her a lot of credit this is a
totally honest argument thank you for
making the honest argument Sophie Lewis
because that's it it's obviously a form
of killing and the argument for abortion
is that you should you can justify that
killing because the comfort of the
mother is more important than the life
of the baby that's that's the argument
and so it is killing it is a human life
it is an individual human life and
you're going to do it and if you want
abortion you have to accept that and you
have to say it's worth killing human
life and she's so good at this actually
she takes the argument to its logical
conclusion which is that it's not just
about when life begins but if you accept
that argument for killing babies based
on your own personal or social
preferences then you should be able to
kill people at the end of their lives as
well and she makes that argument in the
same breath I see the forms of making
and unmaking each other as sort of
continuous processes the other end of
the spectrum is the process of learning
how to die well and hold each other and
let each other go at the end of our
lives as well as at the beginning die
well we'll each other let each other die
well let go which is obviously referring
to as euthanasia so called assisted
suicide Death with Dignity they call it
where you kill old people and you let
old people kill themselves and as a
society you create a lot of incentives
for old people to kill themselves but
sure if you agree with the argument for
abortion that human life does not have
some intrinsic value then of course you
would agree with the argument for
assisted suicide at the end of your life
she makes that honest argument you could
go to youtube watch that argument
and then you could watch another
argument there was a girl an amazing
girl Addison was woolsley 13 years old
went up at the Raleigh City Council and
made an impassioned and utterly coherent
argument against abortion notice they
can recognize their mom's voice they can
be hiccup in their heart is beating on
ultrasound the baby tries to move away
from the disturbing instruments they
throw the babies the babies now to go to
my why do cities remain hill these
things are alive these feelings help it
hurts them and there's exactly thing to
do about it there's no one around it
abortion is murder so why is it if they
pick this rug before birth there's no
problem but until after birth it's
considered a brutal murder these babies
aren't it's or fetuses they are human
the same human right any other person
beautiful argument brilliant argument
I'm often uncomfortable with very young
political activists because they don't
really know much of what they're talking
about and they sound like when David
Hogg opens his mouth he's always totally
incoherent talking about gun control
she's making a coherent argument even if
you disagree with the argument by the
way she's making you reject the premises
or whatever she's making a very
articulate very impassioned obviously
very coherent argument and the people in
that room were very disrespectful to her
when she takes that argument to its
logical conclusion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my dress is made I'm wearin a steaming
upwards right I'm here today speaking
for those who can't speak for themselves
are you choosing the plantation workers
[Applause]
[Music]
that is a powerful video that's a
powerful segment she makes the argument
it's like slavery and we will be judged
by our future generations and who will
you be will you be the plantation owner
the guy whipping the slave or will you
be on the side of justice and that the
you know ironically or I guess maybe not
ironically maybe we should expect this
the thirteen-year-old girl who's
standing up for moral clarity is
behaving like an adult and all those
so-called adults in the room screaming
like children you're a baby
now screaming we can't here this weekend
no trying to drown her out this is you
this is what YouTube is doing this is
what the left is doing this is what the
mainstream media are doing what they're
trying to do is stop you from seeing
both sides that was what YouTube did all
YouTube ever did the great achievement
of YouTube was present both sides
because there weren't gatekeepers in the
early days and so you couldn't shut up
the Conservatives and people were
presented with both sides and guess what
they found the conservative arguments
pretty compelling if you saw those two
arguments the pro-abortion woman and
that thirteen year old little girl of
fairly famous radical feminists and a
thirteen year old little girl totally
obscure they both presented their
arguments for abortion which are you
going to find more compelling obviously
it's that little girls and it's why
YouTube and
times infox calm and the whole
mainstream media have to be like those
shouting idiots in the rally city
council whole trying to scream them down
trying to censor them trying to shut
them up they can't let you hear both
sides because if you do you will side
with the right uppercase R and lowercase
R wish we could get to the Trump Mexico
deal because it was absolutely fabulous
but I'll give you a little preview so
that we can get to it tomorrow and have
the mainstream media are totally lying
about this but the little preview is
this was an unmitigated win for Donald
Trump after negotiating after
threatening tariffs after we heard the
trade war was going to destroy the
global economy
president Trump reached a deal Mexico
made major concessions to fight illegal
immigration on their own southern border
it is a total win it totally vindicates
the use of tariffs threats in
negotiations it vindicates the use of
tariffs threats as the u.s. deals with
China which is a much more important
negotiation and the mainstream media are
furious about it we'll try to get to
that tomorrow to explain how the
mainstream media are trying to spin it
and why just ain't so so tune in for
that in the meantime I'm Michael nose
this is the Michael Nolt show we'll see
you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Matt Walsh show we're going to talk
about the left's increasingly disturbing
and grotesque efforts to normalize
pedophilia we are headed to a very dark
place in this culture and I think we
need to discuss it also a Democratic
presidential candidate reaches the most
extreme levels of pandering imaginable
and a feminist presents what I think is
the only honest argument for abortion
that you will ever hear so we'll talk
about that today as well in the Matt
Walsh show